your intuition that the
there were intelligent civilizations out
there
but it's very possible that they're no
longer there
it's kind of a sad picture they enter
some steady state they all wirehead
themselves what's wirehead
um stimulate stimulate their pleasure
centers
uh and just you know live forever in
this kind of stasis
they become well i mean i think the
reason i believe this is because where
are they
if there's some reason they stopped
expanding
because otherwise they would have taken
over the universe the universe isn't
that big or at least you know let's just
talk about the galaxy right
70 thousand light years across uh i took
that number from star trek voyager i
don't know how true it is
but um uh yeah that's not big
right 70 000 light years is nothing for
some possible technology that you can
imagine that can leverage like wormholes
or something like that
you don't even need wormholes just a von
neumann probe is enough avon
newman probe and a million years of
sublight travel and you'd have taken
over the whole universe
that clearly uh didn't happen so
something stopped it
so you mean if you right for for like a
few million years if you sent out
probes that travel close what's sublight
meaning close to the speed of light
let's say 0.1 and it just spreads
interesting actually that's an
interesting calculation
huh but what makes you think that would
be able to
communicate with them like uh yeah
what's why do you think we would be able
to be able to comprehend
intelligent lives that are out there
like
even if they were among us kind of thing
or even just flying around well
i mean that's possible it's possible
that there is some sort of prime
directive
uh that'd be a really cool universe to
live in um and there's some reason
they're not making themselves visible to
us
but it makes sense that they would use
the same
well at least the same entropy well
you're implying the same laws of physics
i don't know what you mean by entropy in
this case oh wow yeah i mean if entropy
is the scarce resource in the universe
so what do you think about like stephen
wolfram and everything is a computation
and then what if they are traveling
through this world of computation so
if you think of the universe as just
information processing
then uh what you're referring to with
with entropy
and then these these pockets of
interesting complex computations
swimming around
how do we know they're not already here
how do we know that this like all the
different
amazing things that are full of mystery
on earth
are just like little footprints of
intelligence from
light years away maybe i mean
i tend to think that as civilizations
expand they use more and more energy
uh and you can never overcome the
problem of waste heat so where is their
waste heat
so we'd be able to with our crude
methods be able to see like there's a
whole lot of
energy here but it could be something
we're not i mean we don't understand
dark energy right dark matter
it could be just stuff we don't
understand at all or they could have a
fundamentally different physics
you know like that that we just don't
even compromise well i think
okay i mean it depends how far out you
want to go i don't think physics is very
different on the other side of the
galaxy
i would suspect that they have i mean if
they're in our
universe they have the same physics well
yeah that's the assumption we have
but there could be like super trippy
things like
like our cognition
only gets to a slice oh and all the
possible instruments that we can design
only get to a particular slice of the
universe and there's something much
like weirder maybe we can try a thought
experiment
um would people from the past
be able to detect the remnants of our
uh we'll be able to detect our modern
civilization i think the answer is
obviously yes
you mean past from 100 years ago well
let's even go back further
let's go to a million years ago right
the humans who were lying around in the
desert
probably didn't even have maybe they
just barely had fire
uh they would understand if a 747 flew
overhead
oh in in in this vicinity but not um
if the if a 747 flew on mars
because they wouldn't be able to see far
because we're not actually communicating
that well
with the rest of the universe we're
doing okay we're just sending out random
like
50s tracks of music true
and yeah i mean they'd have to you know
the we've only been broadcasting radio
waves for
um 150 years and well there's your light
cone
so
you